hello everyone that's the social media
team at the world they can be forum here
and that would have been signing off i'm
here with Uncle cheeky who has been
Manning this social media corner for the
past two days how was the experience
Thunder it was very very insightful i
actually think i had the funnest part
here at the summit on the Global Agenda
because I got to do to see directly from
one of the greatest World thinkers what
are the new ideas that they were working
on great so you can watch all these new
ideas the new models from the
participants here at the onion first
annual meeting on the global agenda
right on this playlist so thank you very
much once again for watching bye bye bye